bonsoir à tous il ya quelques temps je
me trouvais dans la salle d'attenté
d'une gare et au terme de deux journées
éprouvantes
je me réjouissais davance de lire un bon
bouquin
manque de chance
moins de deux minutes après un homme à
ces jeunes arrivent son téléphone
portable à la main la musique à plein
tube je fulminais intérieurement je vous
laisse imaginer mes jugements après
avoir ruminé un certain temps de qu'il
m'était devenu absolument impossible de
lire je me décide est allé vers ce jeune
homme et à lui dire excusez moi vous
écouter la musique avec le haut parleur
est ce que c'est parce que vous n'avez
pas d'écouteurs ou bien parce que vous
avez envie de mettre de l'ambiance de
nous en faire profiter
il me dit bosch pas d'écouteurs athènes
avait je terminais ma phrase en lui
disant que j'étais gêné qu'un autre
homme jeune lui aussi se lève le sourire
au visage une deuxième paire d'écouteurs
à la main et lui dit tenez j'en ai deux
paires est ce que vous voulez eu du beau
oui il met ses écouteurs il sera si avec
le sourire et moi je me rase y est aussi
assez éberlué je dois dire imaginez ce
que ça aurait donné si je lui ai dit
vous pouvez pas mettre des écouteurs non
vous pouvez imaginer processus
agressivité qui en auraient découlé
en pareille circonstance nous réaction
habituelle son soin de nous taire et de
ne penser pas moins parce que nous avons
peur de dire ou de nous engager dans un
processus agressivité asséné femmes
c'est en 1994 que des amis m'ont invité
à une conférence de communication non
violente je me demandais vraiment
pourquoi il m'invitait parce que je
passais pour quelqu'un de très gentil de
très serviable et ce soir là j'ai
entendu un certain marshall rosenberg
dire que la plupart d'entre nous sommes
de nice dette personnes littéralement de
gentilles personnes mortes
je comprenais vraiment pas de quoi il
parlait je vous avoue je trouvais ça
assez stupide pour moi j'étais médecin
la question de la vie et de la mort
était assez tranché c'était plus la
question de la mort qui me paraissaient
poser problème
je me sentais bien vivant de point barre
mais néanmoins dans les jours qui ont
suivi j'ai prêter davantage attention
aux réactions de mes patients de mes
collègues et moi même et j'ai vu que la
plupart du temps quand il y avait une
difficulté nous réagissions à partir de
nos préjugés et de nos peurs et que
finalement nous passions la plus grande
partie de notre vie dans notre tête et
j'ai commencé à comprendre ce que
rosenberg voulait dire quand il disait
que nous étions des gentils personnes
mortes et je me suis vu moi même comme
une tête à pattes complètement
déconnecté du reste de mon corps et j'ai
réalisé en regardant les patients et mes
collègues à nouveau que la plupart du
temps nous n'écoutions ce qui se passe
dans notre corps que quand nous tombions
malades
nous appelons ça somatisé et que le
reste du temps voilà peu importe qui se
passe autour
si rennes nous sommes vraiment
déconnecté un autre un autre épisode ya
quelque temps je travaillais avec une
équipe hospitalière cette fois je
n'étais plus médecins dans le service
mais j'ai accompagné je forme des
équipes et j'avais des aides soignants
des infirmiers qui étaient extrêmement
mécontents des médecins et des
chirurgiens disant qu'ils étaient
méprisant vis-à-vis du personnel
un infirmier m'a particulièrement marqué
parce qu'il exprimait sa colère avec une
très très grande diversité
disons que les chirurgiens étaient de
véritables chiens maltraitant vis-à-vis
des patients notamment salles
d'opération et je vous assure qu'il
avait l'air extrêmement vivante indiqué
s'exprimer
et pourtant rosenberg dit que quand nous
sommes en colère nous sommes morts
alors c'est quoi être vivant est vivant
c'est ressentir instant par instant ce
qui se passe dans notre corps fait
ressentir nos émotions forts comme la
colère et la peur sentir le coeur qui
s'accélère sentir les sueurs sentir les
mâchoires qui serre les poings serrés
prêt à bondir
si aussi prendre conscience de nos
pensées de nos image d'ennemi telles que
celles que je pouvais avoir vis-à-vis de
ce jeune dans la salle d'attenté
et puis à partir de notre sentier de nos
pensées tourner son regard vers
l'intérieur et se dire mais au fond
voilà qu'est ce qui fait que ça ne va
pas et se mettre en lien avec nos
besoins des aspirations quelque chose
qui n'est pas satisfait dans le cadre de
ces soignants en service hospitalier
leur indignation leur colère venaient
d'un besoin de respect que tous les
êtres humains soient traités avec
respect vivre et travailler dans un
climat de respect de la dignité de
chacun ça paraît normal
cette capacité à ressentir ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de nous et à nommer
nos sentiments et nos besoins et la
première clé du vivre ensemble des
chercheurs en sciences de l'éducation
ont montré que la violence était liée à
un déficit de langage intérieur une
difficulté a nommé ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de nous le fait de ressentir
des sensations désagréables des
symptômes physiques est hyper important
une douleur m'informe que mon intégrité
que ma santé est menacée et va m'amener
à consulter
de la même manière des émotions des
sensations désagréables tel qu'une
indignation face à comportement me
mettre en contact avec un besoin de
respect et il apporte de faire grand cas
de ses émotions et de ses sensations
désagréables
ce sont des clignotants des signaux
d'alarmé
faute d'en tenir compte soit du tombeau
malades soit ne nous enfermons nous en
voulons aux autres et tôt ou tard tout
le monde est perdant
nous faisons payer
notre ressenti et le contact avec nos
besoins c'est ça qui va nous mettre en
mouvement une douleur à la poitrine
naturellement m'amène à décrocher mon
téléphone aller voir le médecin un
cardiologue ou le samu si c'est sérieux
une indignation face à un comportement
me met en contact avec un besoin de
respect que chaque être humain soit
respectée et devrait m'amener à en faire
quelque chose mais pourtant c'est pas
facile de dire on a énormément de peur
qu'ils vont nous retenir alors dans
l'exemple de la salle d'attenté avec ce
jeune dans la salle d'attenté de la gare
qu'est ce qui m'a permis de m'exprimer
de prendre mon courage à deux mains et
bien ce sont deux autres clés la
première c'est de me souvenir que les
besoins de l'autre sont aussi importants
que les miens ce jeune homme dans la
salle d'attenté il avait tout autant
besoin de passer un bon moment et de se
détendre que moi et la troisième clé je
dirais encore plus importante c'est
celle de l'intention
quand je suis allé vers ce jeune homme
mon intention n'était aucunement qu'il
arrête sa musique c'était uniquement de
créer un contact la troisième clé de
vivre ensemble et de l'art de se rendre
la vie plus belle
c'est de mettre la relation en priorité
aux résultats ce qui veut dire que c'est
uniquement une fois que j'ai eus digérer
ma colère et mais image d'ennemi que
j'ai pu m'avancer vers cet homme libre
de toute exigence à son égard
et c'est là que la rencontre a pu se
passer mais soyons honnête j'y arrive
pas tous les jours je suis loin d'être
parfaite et c'est pas le but
un important c'est d'être simplement
plus conscience qui se passe pour nous
mais ce qui m'aide c'est de faire ce que
je fais ce soir et ce que j'ai fait en
préparant cette conférence c'est me
souvenir des moments où ça a marché et
où cette relation de qualité
cette rencontre entre deux êtres humains
puissent passer et cette quatrième clé
c'est la gratitude
j'y reviendrai en détail tout à l'heure
parce qu'elle est fondamentale pour se
rendre la vie plus belle
et pour le vivre ensemble
alors je vous disais que c'est pas si
facile d'y arriver parce qu'on a
énormément de peur a osé dire
alors que faire de nos peurs
premièrement les reconnaître
nos peurs elles sont alimentées par les
préjugés les images que nous avons d
autres les jugements les jugements qui
sont eux-mêmes alimenté par le manque de
curiosité intellectuelle et la pensée
tout fait nos peurs de dire elles sont
également alimentées par les étiquettes
que nous nous mettons ou que les
institutions dans lesquelles nous
travaillons nous mettons très souvent en
milieu hospitalier les jambes 18 mois je
ne suis qu est soignantes ou agent de
service hospitalier ou secrétaires ou
même infirmière je ne peux rien dire
donc nous nous rapetisse on est nous
abdiquons notre pouvoir mais une des
causes majeures de la peur d'oser dire
c'est la peur de la réaction de l'autre
la peur que ça casse le lien ou la peur
de perdre les stimule amitié ou la peur
parfois d'une violence physique qui nous
retient ça m'arrive parfois dans les
transports en commun
donc que faire c'est déjà ressentir la
peur faire le lien avec ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur de nous donc les besoins
dans le cadre de ces infirmiers ou de
ces soignants dans le service où il
avait tellement ces images que les
chirurgiens étaient des chiens
c'était le besoin de respecter en même
temps la peur dans les hiérarchies
faisaient qu'il n'osait pas dire donc il
y avait le besoin de sécurité par
rapport aux sanctions mais très souvent
j'ai besoin d'être rassurés par la
qualité du lien et le simple fait de
connecter mon ressenti et mes besoins
en fait me redresse et me redonne de la
force quand j'ai l'impression d'être
méprisés je suis là possibles sont pas à
la hauteur je suis moi le fait de
contact et que j'ai envie de vivre des
relations d'égal à égal
déjà me redonne mon pouvoir et à partir
du moment où j'ai récupéré mon pouvoir
je vais pouvoir parler et oser ma
vulnérabilité et pouvoir exposer ma
vulnérabilité
c'est également une force et vous pouvez
le faire et vous allez le faire
instantanément
là tout de suite je vous propose de vous
mettre en lien avec une situation dans
un collectif auquel vous appartenez dans
lequel un besoin important pour vous
n'est pas satisfait
et santé ce que ça fait dans votre corps
maintenant une autre clé importante une
autre composante importante de vivre
ensemble c'est l'empathie l'empathie ça
veut dire se déplacer là je vous ai
parlé du contact avec soin ce qu'on
ressent maintenant je vous propose vous
proposer de vous déplacer et de décoller
les étiquettes les préjugés dont je
parlais pour chercher à rejoindre
l'être humain est ce qu'il y a de vivant
chez lui revenons à nos médecin
l'infirmier qui les traite est véritable
chien
incidemment dans le cours de la
formation j'ai entendu les entendu dire
ah oui un jour il a dit mais c'est parce
que j'ai peur en fait c'est parce que je
suis timide que je gueule et vous
remarquerez que bien des attitudes de
pouvoir et de domination
elles viennent en fait de peur
inconsciente donc quand je leur ai fait
travailler l'empathie il a été en mesure
de rejoindre l'humanité et de se rendre
compte que quand il est content il avait
un comportement exécrable de mépris
vis-à-vis des patients vis-à-vis du
personnel
en fait cet homme essayait de s'affirmer
pour surmonter sa timidité et chemin
faisant
tandis qu'il essayait de se relier à
l'humanité de cet homme il a constaté
que ces peurs diminué et qu'il
s'installait dans une relation d'égal à
égal
quelque temps après il a pu revenir dans
le service et il a à nouveau été témoin
d'une scène de mépris ou sur rojas
exprimé d'une manière franchement
déplaisante et notamment aussi par
rapport à une élève infirmière qui avait
donné à manger un malade qui qui devait
être à jeun il était vraiment odieux et
il a respiré
il a pensé à faire ce pas de côté et il
a dit oui j'ai l'impression que là vous
étiez vraiment énervé parce que ça
contrariait armand votre emploi du temps
ça décale l intervention etc et à une
autre occasion il a pu lui dire est-ce
que je peux quelque chose pour vous
voyez du fait de semaine dans cette
attitude d'empathie cet infirmier avait
récupéré son pouvoir
deux êtres humains pouvaient se
rencontrer dans leur humanité dans leur
vulnérabilité
c'est pas si facile et en même temps
cette exceptionnelle quand ça se passe
la quatrième plaie du vivre ensemble je
vous le disais c'est la gratitude
la gratitude ça veut dire s'émerveiller
de ce que les uns et les autres nous
faisons au quotidien pour contribuer à
rendre la vie plus belle
ça peut être la gratitude vis-à-vis
d'eux soit la gratitude vis-à-vis de
quelqu'un d'autre
la gratitude vis-à-vis de l'univers dans
l'exemple de la salle d'attenté de la
gare
je suis allé vers cet homme et je les
remercier chaleureusement du geste qu'il
avait fait de tendre ses écouteurs et
juridiques parce que bien sûr ça m'avait
apporté du calme mais que plus encore
son geste m'avait rassuré sur je dirais
cet élan naturel qu'à l'être humain de
contribuer à ce rendre la vie plus belle
j'ai constaté que c'était ça mon besoin
le plus important et en voyant le
sourire de cet homme quand il avait
tendu ses écouteurs et quand moi je les
remercier j'ai vraiment senti que lui
aussi il avait eu énormément de joie à
pouvoir contribuer à rendre la vie plus
belle celle de jeunes hommes la mienne
et puis celle des autres personnes dans
la salle d'attenté parce que le climat
était assez tendue et là maintenant je
voudrais remercier les organisateurs de
tedx qui m'ont permis de réfléchir à ce
thème de vivre ensemble c'était pas mal
de travail de préparer cette conférence
pour faire concis mais ces deux mots ce
sont juxtaposés vivre et ensemble et je
me suis rendu compte que pour bien vivre
ensemble
il fallait déjà bien vivre avec soi même
et être vraiment vivant est bien vivante
être un bon vivant et ce soir là je
voulais vraiment vous offrir ces quatre
clés pourraient tous de bons vivants et
se rendre mutuellement la vie plus belle
un identifiée nommée notre sentier nos
besoins de se souvenir que les besoins
de l'autre et des autres sont aussi
importants que les autres que les nôtres
troisièmement placer la relation en
priorité aux résultats et quatrièmement
accordé une grande place à la gratitude
sans s'oublier soi-même dans la salles
d'attentes pour être honnête à la fin
dans le train je me suis félicité
d'avoir eu ce courage d'aller vers cet
homme plutôt que de rester dans un
silence toxiques et d'infecter de
polluer la salle d'attenté avec ma
colère et mes jugements parce que les
jugements non exprimés sont souvent
beaucoup plus violent qu'une bonne
colère qui est exprimée
et puis je voudrais vous offrir une
cinquième clé qu'elle a plus important
que vous allez pouvoir exercer j'espère
dès ce soir au même pendant le pot en
sortant c'est oser dire est demandée
pour que l'autre puisse avoir la joie
d'exercer sa générosité
j'étais vraiment touchée de voir combien
ce jeune homme était heureux d'avoir pu
lui aussi faire un geste exercer sa
générosité
je vous remercie